l'entanglement quantistico permette alle particelle di essere collegate indipendentemente dallo spazio che le separa, ed è così controintuitivo
che persino Einstein non pensava fosse vero. Nell'episodio di oggi di Qiskit in the Classroom parleremo di come il teorema di Bell
abbia dimostrato che Einstein
aveva torto. Benvenuto a Qiskit in the Classroom. In questa serie useremo Qiskit per esplorare alcuni concetti fondamentali comunemente
trattati nei corsi legati al quantum computing. Ogni video sarà anche accompagnato da un modulo interattivo
linkato nella descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di darci un'occhiata. Nel video dei quanti quantistici abbiamo discusso come misurare una
sovrapposizione quantistica sia un processo intrinsecamente probabilistico, un po' come lanciare una moneta. Ma come facciamo a saperlo?
Potrebbe essere che una particella quantistica nasconda segretamente un risultato predeterminato di una misurazione ma in qualche modo noi non riusciamo a
catturare questa informazione nella nostra teoria? Nei primi giorni della meccanica quantistica questa domanda fu oggetto
di accesi dibattiti, con due fazioni principali. Da una parte c'era Einstein, che credeva che la meccanica quantistica fosse incompleta,
ovvero che mancassero alcune variabili necessarie per descrivere completamente un sistema. Einstein pensava che
queste cosiddette variabili nascoste, se trovate, avrebbero risolto alcuni degli aspetti apparentemente paradossali e probabilistici
della meccanica quantistica. Dall'altra parte c'era Max Born. Born sosteneva
che la descrizione probabilistica fornita dalla meccanica quantistica è tutto ciò che è specificato dalla natura. In altre parole,
non è solo che non conosciamo lo stato di una particella prima di misurarla: è che la particella non ha uno stato definito
prima di essere misurata. Per decenni molti pensavano che questo disaccordo fosse una questione filosofica che non sarebbe mai
stata risolta. Dopotutto, per conoscere qualcosa di un sistema dobbiamo misurarlo. Come possiamo mai sapere
qualcosa sulla natura di uno stato prima della sua misurazione? Poi nel 1964 il fisico
John Bell trovò un modo. Nel suo articolo, Bell esaminò le correlazioni statistiche tra le misurazioni di una coppia di
particelle entangled. Se prima della misurazione gli stati delle particelle fossero determinati da qualche variabile nascosta sconosciuta,
allora Bell scoprì che le loro correlazioni avevano un limite superiore. D'altra parte, quando calcolò le
correlazioni previste dalla meccanica quantistica, scoprì che violavano questo limite. Aveva quindi trovato un modo per distinguere una volta
per tutte tra il punto di vista di Einstein e quello di Born. Non restava che verificare sperimentalmente
queste correlazioni con particelle reali per vedere se obbedivano alle statistiche delle variabili nascoste o
violavano quella regola. Questi test furono eseguiti con crescente precisione e sofisticazione
nel corso degli anni e sono alcuni degli esperimenti più significativi della fisica moderna. Erano così rivoluzionari che
fecero vincere il Premio Nobel a tre fisici nel 2022. Ma oggi chiunque può eseguire un
test di Bell. Tutto ciò che serve è un po' di conoscenza di Qiskit e l'accesso a un computer quantistico IBM. In questo video ti
mostrerò la logica della disuguaglianza di Bell, poi ti mostrerò come possiamo testare le previsioni di Bell su un
computer quantistico IBM. La disuguaglianza di Bell coinvolge alcune misurazioni diverse e livelli di logica, e può essere un
po' difficile da seguire, ma la vedremo passo dopo passo e alla fine ne varrà la pena. Stiamo per mostrare
che l'entanglement è reale e che Einstein aveva torto. Non sono in molti a poter dire di averlo fatto. Ecco dunque
cosa propose Bell. Diciamo che hai un modo per produrre molte copie di una coppia entangled di particelle. Fisicamente,
queste coppie potrebbero essere prodotte tramite un processo di decadimento in cui una particella decade in due. Se hai guardato il video sull'
esperimento di Stern-Gerlach, sai che le particelle possono avere un momento angolare intrinseco chiamato
spin. Diciamo che una particella con spin zero decade in due particelle con spin 1/2.
Allora ciascuna delle particelle con spin 1/2 può essere misurata come spin +1/2 o -1/2,
detti anche spin su o spin giù. Ma siccome sono decadute da una particella con spin zero, i due spin devono combinarsi per avere
uno spin totale di zero. Quindi se uno viene misurato come su, l'altro deve essere
giù e viceversa. Queste particelle formano una coppia entangled che ha questo aspetto.
Quindi se uno viene misurato come su, l'altro è giù e viceversa. Diciamo che la particella uno vola verso sinistra, cioè nella
direzione -X, dove un ricercatore che chiameremo Lucas ne misura lo
spin. Poi la particella due vola analogamente verso destra,
dove un'altra ricercatrice, Rihanna, può misurare quello spin. Lucas e Rihanna possono indipendentemente
ruotare i loro dispositivi di misurazione per scegliere di misurare lo spin delle rispettive particelle lungo qualsiasi direzione
perpendicolare alla direzione di moto della particella. Se mandiamo molte copie dello stato entangled a Lucas
e Rihanna, possono raccogliere statistiche delle misurazioni. Se misurano sempre lungo lo stesso asse, queste statistiche non saranno
molto interessanti: ogni volta che uno misura spin su, l'altro misura spin giù, e ogni volta che uno misura spin
avanti, l'altro misura spin indietro, e così via. Ma se i due ricercatori misurano lungo assi diversi, potremmo trovare
qualcosa di più interessante. Diamo a Lucas e Rihanna tre assi lungo i quali
misurare. Chiameremo questi assi a, b e c, e sono ciascuno separati di
120°. La domanda che porremo con questo esperimento è: se Lucas e Rihanna sono liberi di misurare lungo uno qualsiasi dei tre
assi, con quale frequenza i due otterranno lo stesso segno? Chiaramente se Lucas e Rihanna misurano lungo lo stesso asse,
diciamo l'asse a, non possono mai ottenere lo stesso segno poiché le particelle devono combinarsi per avere spin zero. Ma quando scelgono
assi diversi, come saranno correlate le loro misurazioni, se lo sono? Secondo Einstein, questa descrizione
quantomeccanica dello stato della particella è incompleta. Pensava che dovessero esistere variabili nascoste che
predeterminano il risultato di tutte le possibili misurazioni di spin, poiché senza di esse le particelle entangled dovrebbero
comunicare istantaneamente l'esito della loro misurazione l'una all'altra. Se una veniva misurata come
su da qualche parte, l'altra dovrebbe istantaneamente sapere di essere giù dall'altra
parte. Queste variabili nascoste potrebbero essere qualsiasi insieme complicato di istruzioni per l'esito degli esperimenti, ma il punto è
che lo stato di spin di ciascuna particella separatamente è determinato, così non è necessaria alcuna comunicazione.
WEBVTT
Sperimentalmente, ciò significherebbe che le misurazioni di Lucas non avrebbero effetto sulla particella di Rihanna e viceversa.
Questo potrebbe porre dei limiti a quanto correlate possono essere le due misurazioni. Secondo Born, invece, questo stato
psi è tutto ciò che si può dire sulla coppia di particelle prima della misurazione, quindi la misurazione di una particella
influenza l'esito della misurazione dell'altra. Questo potrebbe avere implicazioni diverse per le correlazioni tra misurazioni. Vediamo come ciascuna
teoria influenza queste correlazioni. Nel trattamento delle variabili nascoste, esiste un insieme segreto di istruzioni prima della
misurazione che determina già cosa misurerà Lucas lungo ciascuno dei tre assi. Per esempio, queste
istruzioni potrebbero essere: positivo se Lucas misura lungo l'asse a,
positivo se misura lungo b e negativo se misura lungo c. Possiamo
scrivere questo come +a, +b e -c. Allora la particella di Rihanna
dovrebbe avere le variabili -a, -b e +c per assicurarsi che lo spin
totale lungo una qualsiasi singola direzione sia zero.
Ci sono otto insiemi di possibili istruzioni che soddisfano questo vincolo di spin zero. Quindi ogni volta che una nuova coppia di
particelle viene inviata a Lucas e Rihanna, potrebbe contenere uno qualsiasi di questi otto insiemi di istruzioni. Ora vogliamo
capire, assumendo che le particelle contengano uno degli insiemi segreti di istruzioni forniti nella tabella, e
assumendo che Lucas e Rihanna scelgano ciascuno indipendentemente quale dei tre assi misurare, qual è la
probabilità che misurino entrambi lo stesso segno? Se le istruzioni sono quelle date nelle righe 1 o
8, allora chiaramente questa probabilità è zero, poiché le due particelle avranno segni opposti indipendentemente dagli assi di
misurazione. Ma cosa succede con le istruzioni nella riga due? Misurerebbero gli stessi segni se
Rihanna misurasse lungo c e Lucas misurasse lungo a o b, oppure se Lucas
misurasse lungo c e Rihanna misurasse lungo a o b. Sono quindi quattro su nove delle
possibili combinazioni di misurazione che daranno a Lucas e Rihanna lo stesso segno. Se facciamo questo per
ciascun insieme di istruzioni, vediamo che le righe da 3 a 7 danno anch'esse una probabilità di 4/9. Ciò significa che se
Einstein ha ragione e variabili nascoste come queste predeterminano l'esito delle misurazioni, non è possibile per Lucas
e Rihanna misurare mai lo stesso segno con probabilità maggiore di 4/9. Questa è la disuguaglianza di Bell: P minore o uguale
a 4/9. E come mostreremo, le particelle entangled la violano. Per vedere cosa predice la meccanica quantistica,
diciamo che Lucas misura lungo a. Possono succedere due cose: o misura spin su, quindi
Rihanna misurerà spin giù lungo a, oppure misura spin giù e Rihanna misurerà spin su lungo a. Ma
vogliamo la probabilità che Rihanna misuri lo stesso segno di Lucas lungo qualsiasi asse a sua scelta, non solo a. Se
misura lungo b o c, diventa un po' più complicato. Si scopre che
se sai cosa misurerà Rihanna con il 100% di certezza lungo una direzione, puoi calcolare le probabilità
che misuri su o giù lungo qualsiasi altro asse con un po' di geometria.
Se il tuo stato misura sempre spin su lungo un asse, la probabilità di misurare spin su lungo un asse diverso
sarà uguale al quadrato del coseno di metà dell'angolo tra i due assi. È un po' complicato, ma
ti mostro cosa intendo. Se Lucas misura spin su lungo a, sappiamo con il 100% di certezza che Rihanna misurerebbe
spin giù se misurasse lungo a. Quindi possiamo rappresentarlo con un vettore
così. In questo caso gli angoli tra questo vettore e gli altri due assi di misurazione b e c sono entrambi
60°. Quindi metà di questo è 30°, e il coseno di
30° è mostrato qui. Coseno al quadrato di
30° uguale 3/4. Ora, se Lucas misura spin giù
lungo a, sappiamo che Rihanna misurerà spin su lungo a. Quindi possiamo disegnare un altro vettore qui. Ora
questo vettore che rappresenta questa conoscenza è a 120° da ciascuno degli altri due assi b
e c. Quindi possiamo fare lo stesso trucco geometrico, ma questa volta otterremo coseno di
60°. Quindi coseno al quadrato di
60° uguale 1/4. Poiché Lucas ha uguale probabilità di
misurare spin su e spin giù lungo a, dobbiamo fare la media di queste due probabilità di Rihanna. Otteniamo una probabilità finale
che Rihanna misuri lo stesso segno di Lucas pari a 1/2. Quindi P
uguale 1/2. 1/2 è maggiore di 4/9, quindi la disuguaglianza di Bell è violata.
Ciò significa che, finché valgono le regole della meccanica quantistica, le variabili nascoste sono impossibili. Ora possiamo usare Qiskit e un
computer quantistico IBM per testare la disuguaglianza di Bell con vere misurazioni quantistiche. Possiamo mappare gli stati spin su e
spin giù delle particelle di Lucas e Rihanna agli stati zero e uno dei qubit nel computer quantistico. Prenderemo
due qubit, uno per rappresentare la particella di Lucas e uno per quella di Rihanna, e li faremo entangle con questo circuit quantistico.
I due qubit sono rappresentati dai due fili q0 e q1, e questa combinazione
di gate X, Hadamard e C-not creerà lo stesso stato entangled che avevamo tra le particelle di Lucas e Rihanna. Ora
dobbiamo misurare ciascun qubit. Impostiamo la misurazione di Lucas lungo a, che diciamo essere l'asse Z. Poi la misurazione di Rihanna
può essere lungo a, b o c, quindi avremo bisogno di tre circuit separati per ciascuno di questi tre casi. Ma in questo
video ne faremo solo uno. Puoi andare al modulo linkato nella descrizione per la versione completa. Se Rihanna misura lungo
b, allora il nostro circuit ha questo aspetto, dove ry è una rotazione di 120° per cambiare
l'asse di misurazione di Rihanna. Possiamo usare il Qiskit Primitive sampler per eseguire questo esperimento molte volte e raccogliere
statistiche dalle misurazioni risultanti. Le due colonne 0 0 e 1 1 rappresentano le volte in cui Lucas e
Rihanna hanno misurato lo stesso segno, che è ciò che ci interessa. Quindi la probabilità di misurare entrambe le particelle con lo stesso
segno è molto vicina a 1/2. Questo viola la disuguaglianza di Bell. Questo significa
WEBVTT
che le due particelle sono entangled. Ciascuna sembra in qualche modo sapere istantaneamente i risultati della
misurazione dell'altra. C'è ancora qualche disaccordo su come interpretare esattamente questo
entanglement e cosa succede quando misuri uno stato entangled, ma queste domande sono più filosofiche. La
teoria è abbastanza innegabile a questo punto: l'entanglement è decisamente reale, e lo sappiamo grazie a Bell, alla sua
disuguaglianza e ai molti fisici che hanno eseguito esperimenti per testarla. Se vuoi essere annoverato tra quei
fisici ed eseguire il tuo test di Bell con un computer quantistico, assicurati di andare al modulo della disuguaglianza di Bell
linkato nella descrizione. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.